tell me you're not thinking of taking
the black and go celibate the
would go begging from Dorne to Casterly
Rock hey youtubers it's Charlie so Game
of Thrones season 4 just cast Pedro
Pascal as the biggest new cast member on
Game of Thrones that's right he's going
to be playing the red Viper Oberyn
Martell since he's gonna be such a big
deal in season four I thought I'd give
him his own video but first I'll talk a
little bit about who he is and who the
Martel's are and then I'll talk a little
bit about spoilers so don't worry
there'll be a big spoiler warning so the
red Viper is the younger brother of the
Prince of Dorne think of it as like the
really sandy southern Beach area of
Westeros like the California of Westeros
basically very sunny very hot lots of
beaches I like to think of the red Viper
is a really dark version of Loras he's a
really amazing fighter in fact the only
person in Westeros they could really
beat him is dead it was rigged our
Targaryen is the only one of the only
people in addition to Barristan Selmy
you unhorsed him in a tournament another
really important thing for his character
is that when he was younger he actually
studied to be a maester but quit halfway
through he actually has a really working
knowledge of medicine and poisons which
will come in to the spoiler section so
one of the other really awesome things
about him is that he has these eight
bastard daughters that they call the
sand snakes they're not technically a
mercenary band but they call them the
sand snakes because they're basically
badasses think of them like the uma
thurman character in Kill Bill basically
just a really really badass fighter in
fact I think it's only a coincidence
that the characters and uma thurman's
assassin group were nicknamed after
snakes but one of the other really cool
things is is that the red Vipers nephew
is actually named Quentin I don't know
Quentin Tarantino sand snakes the Mamba
you know who it all gets really meta and
really funny just a coincidence I don't
know let me know you think write in the
comments if you think that Quentin
Tarantino actually read A Song of Ice
and Fire I don't know that the book
would have been quite been out at the
time because I think the movie was
around 1995 someone might be able to
correct me on this one of the other
really cool things about Dorne that's
different from the other places in
Westeros are is that women have status
so if you remember seriously is actually
always complained a lot about how she
wishes she had been born a man so the
people would listen to what she has to
say she you know has all these things to
offer but no
wants to hear because she's a woman well
if she had been born in Dorne that
actually would not have been a problem
for her she would have grown up and been
very powerful another important thing to
understand about the Martel's are is
that Elia Targaryen who was murdered
during the rebellion against the crown
was actually a Martell because of a deal
that he made with Tyrion when Marcella
got sent to Dorne in season two the red
Viper is now coming to King's Landing in
season four to get a seat on the small
Council as minor reparations for his
sister's death he's also gonna spend a
lot of the season trying to find out who
actually killed his sister we'll talk
more about that in spoilers which are
actually coming in way for it now
okay we're in spoiler territory now so
let's talk about the awesome stuff so
after the events of the purple wedding
Tyrion is put on trial and the red Viper
is one of his judges now because it's
such an amazing fighter and Tyrion
chooses trial by combat just like he did
in season 1 if you remember that the red
Viper agrees to fight for Tyrion if
Tyrion will tell him who actually killed
his sister
and obviously Tyrion agrees because he
has to fight the mountain that
crazy brother of the Hound you remember
him so the red Viper finds out from
Tyrion that it was actually Gregor
Clegane that killed and raped his sister
so naturally he proceeds to kick the
out of him in this trial by combat
I won't tell you what happens at the end
of this battle but the battle itself is
really really awesome because until now
we basically thought that the mountain
is invincible in battle he's just so
huge even his brother the hound almost
died until the king actually told him to
stop you remember that moment in season
1 during that tournament I mean think
about it the mountain is the only
character on a game of Thrones that I
can think of that is worse than Joffrey
he's basically like Joffrey on steroids
revenge will be had sweet sweet revenge
don't you just feel like it's really
satisfying when you actually see someone
get revenge on a game of Thrones we
don't really get a lot of those moments
because so many good characters end up
dying and don't even get me started on
the red wedding Jesus Christ that's it
for spoilers and if you guys haven't
seen it yet I just posted a thank you
video to all of you guys for helping me
get to 5,000 subscribers so fast it's
only been a couple months but it's been
amazing I also talked about some really
really big videos that are coming this
summer as well as a lot of comic-con
stuff that's coming in the next couple
of weeks
be sure to subscribe to get all those
videos in the meantime you can click
here to watch that big Avengers 2 Joss
Whedon update and you can click here to
watch that big thank you video thank you
so much for watching you guys double
high-fives to everyone you're totally
awesome to infinity and beyond
you